today I'm going to talk about the
runtime Liberia runtime like this part
of Mathematica and it's part of the GNU
Compiler it's part of the old compiler
it's essentially a cord shared component
for numerical computation it's focus is
on machine arithmetic fast machine
arithmetic today I'm going to describe
the design and new work to improve it
and when I described the new performance
enhancement so even if you just use the
Mathematica as a casual user nothing to
do with the compiler you will see some
benefits from using it in the next
version but of course the benefits will
be more significant if you use it
through the new compiler infrastructure
so as I said the well from RTL is here
is sitting in the middle here its
services the kernel when the kernel does
machine arithmetic it services the new
compiler and the old compiler it also
supports when standalone code is
generated it it supports the functions
generated in the standalone code it also
supports the library library link
function and every link and for the
future I'm told that there's some
interesting very high up in the front
end group to start using Wolfram rtl in
the future so what happens in the kernel
the kernel has interpreted code at some
point that interpreted code needs to do
some machinery thematic or packed array
computation and then that's passed over
to the Wolfram runtime and IB where the
actual computation is done so it's the
home of where yeah so here's a little
graphic that I took from abdel's talk
here so this is like a schematic of the
gnu compiler with the type analysis the
absolute abstract syntax tree
instruction registers and more from RTL
is down here when the code generation
and the actual computation so the
runtime library provides core data
structures and operations for the kernel
and the compiler m-pesa which is the
heart of the pack to rake the sparse
array machines Basara computation and
new in this version is the numeric array
he went to pee otters talk you would
have seen that generalization of pacta
raised to an extended set of types 8-bit
16-bit machine integers floats etc it
provides machine arithmetic for scalar
and vector operations call linear
algebra operations dense and sparse
pilars random number generation has hash
functions hash tables they're used in
the kernel
it has a fast thread-safe memory
allocator it also provides a threading
layer which which will then abstract
away to a system pacific platform
specific thread like p threads on linux
or something so more recently we've
added support for many many more types
in order to be able to support numeric
array and all order to be able to
compile to different types in the gnu
compiler so 8 16 32 64 bits signed and
unsigned integers 62 64 and 32 bit
floats which are native and we use a
little library available for all
platforms to be able to perform a rhythm
16-bit floats which are generally only
available on GPUs but we want to provide
that functionality even on a CPU so you
could develop your code using a smaller
floating-point footprint and then go and
take it over to a GPU and also a lot of
new support functions for the new
compiler so the design it's it's
standard compliant so we use a C++
specific standard it has platform
specific optimizations like compiler
intrinsic functions and it used this
special-purpose arithmetic oriented
libraries like intel's mkl or IPP the
objectives of the Mathematica compiler
would be to generate more efficient
compiled code to extend Mathematica
using the new compiler instead of having
to write stuff in the kernel and then
also to provide the user with some sort
of code that runs just as efficiently as
as something that would be built into
the kernel so those are the objectives
so here's an example
interpreted computation done through
Mathematica through the evaluator so
we'll just take the maximum machine
integer on this machine 2 to the 32 to
the 63 minus 1 signed integer we'll add
1 to it this is then interpreted
mathematic goes down to its plus
function the plus function calls the
runtime library the runtime library says
this is too big to fit into a signed
machine integer and it returns an error
code back so the kernel plus function
then says oh oh dear I'd better go and
redo that computation and the
computations returned as a big integer
so that errors trapped and then the
kernel will go and use its extended set
of types to be able to go and carry on
the computation and so the result is no
longer a machine integer but inside as
an intermediary set there's been a call
out to the runtime library and it's been
able to determine that the result
couldn't be done using machine integers
similar sort of thing with packed arrays
of floating-point numbers so you have
made a small packed array and I've set
the last entry to be the maximum machine
number it's a packed array you can take
the square root of this packed array and
this is done using vectorized arithmetic
then but if I square that nut square
that packed array then this number is
too big to be represented as an I Triple
E floating point number so what happens
if the runtime mode does the computation
finds that there's been a floating-point
overflow error returns that back to the
kernel and then the kernel will go and
take some course of action unpack the
factory and then go and do the
evaluation using its own expression
expression arithmetic the result is then
an arbitrary precision floating point
number so we've reimplemented the
runtime library
it's the previous versions were written
in seeing that now it's written in C++
not all of the code is being converted
yet I'd say about half of it something
like that some of the things that we
wanted from C++ templates obviously we
have an extended set of types many many
new types and the template mechanism
super thrust was quite important also
operator and functional
the loading was quite important the fact
that you can use classes to reorganize
work was very important this becoming
quite a big project to now and we want a
better kind of organizational
infrastructure C++ provides that
performance well what I mean by
performance is C++ has this ability to
do more work at compile time and less
work at runtime if you set things up
properly you can push work into the
compiler so it takes longer to actually
for us to build and compile the runtime
library but then the user who uses the
library actually has code executes more
quickly another thing that we found
useful and this is very project specific
is the fact that you can use exceptions
in C++ so in our old C interface we
would pass around flags to say there's
been an error propagated then you need
to go and check that flag if there's a
flag return an error flag okay and
that's very apart from the fact that
you're paying the price of adding is
statements everywhere is so error-prone
you forget to put it in one place and
that exception is not caught and not
returned to the kernel so we use C++
exceptions now if there's no exception
occurred you pay no penalty there's no
longer tests of an if statement of a
flag for every single function so the
code runs more and more efficiently so
here's an example in the gnu compiler
you've seen this already his is a
function with the typed markup and it's
just adding to 64-bit integers together
then i'm going to compile this using the
gnu compiler and it looks like this in
two stages so the first thing it does is
generate this system plus interface
layer and then the system plus interface
layer calls here down into the runtime
library where the actually arithmetic is
performed and then later in some later
compiler pass this might be inlined back
into here and we're only left with the
call out to the runtime library that
actually does this plus operation
so another thing we've been working on
is as we overhaul the codes we're not
just going to see if less are also
trying to incorporate algorithmic
improvements so here's one example
integer powers so in the new version of
Mathematica if you compute 3 to the
power of 39 that's about 50 to 60
percent faster so that'sthat's achieved
in two ways one is to use an optimized
loop unrolled code I'll explain a little
bit up in these ampuls and another is an
algorithmic improvement that I'll also
explain so the first thing is when you
compute integer powers you don't compute
them as successive multiplications XOR
15 would need 14 multiplications you do
it with what's called binary
exponentially exponentiation so you go
through the binary representation of 15
and depending on if it's a 1 or a 0 you
Square and if there's a 1 present you
also do a multiplication so this is like
an SSA form single Asst static
assignment that's used inside the
compiler so you compute x squared then X
cubed then X to the 6 then X to the 7 X
is 14 and finally X to the 15 ok so it
cost three squarings three
multiplications that's six products then
if you want to compute a larger power
you take up where you left off you do
another squaring the multiplication of
the squaring of multiplication when you
get X to the 63 which is ten products so
it looks like this these are the powers
that I want to compute and as I go
further down the tree I need an extra
multiplication they go down nothing
you'll notice that when I compute X to
the 39 here it's actually more expensive
than computing X to the 40 even though
naught is larger than 39 so we did was
build in what's called an addition chain
exponentiation so addition changes
sequences of index pairs such that each
term is the sum of two previous terms so
it turns out that binary explanations
not optimal in some certain cases you
can get an integer explanation more
efficiently so the first power at which
this occurs is X to the 15 so here's
example we square multiply square like
for but now we compute instead of
computing X to the 7 we compute X to the
12 and we compute X to the 15 as X to
the 12 times X to the 3 so this is now
only five products and we saved one
product and a similar kind of thing for
X to the 63 X to the 63 is the first
power at which you can actually save two
products compared to the binary
explanation exponentiation so here's the
tree for the addition chain and you'll
see it's a lot shallower and a lot more
dense around here work being saved so
nothing that we really had to do was to
break some kind of backward
compatibility so this is what happened
in version 11.3 and they haven't been
too many users complaints but there was
a fair amount of work inside the company
so hopefully those who view audits
they've did pearl Eduardo go share
people who did put work into to doing
this I'm hopefully going to convince you
it was all worth it so the whole point
of this is that machine under flows
holding us back from doing very sick
very efficient vectorized machine
arithmetic computation so oops
so in inversion 11.3 we now just issue a
message but we we allow the machine
under flow to occur instead of going and
switching to a very very small big big
num this allows fast rectoress mythic it
allows us to use much larger set of
algorithms and libraries and I'll show
you a couple of examples so first of all
before I go and show the examples that
may explain a bit about how the vector
arithmetic works in parallel say I want
to compute a long vector and some
operation on that long vector plus x
power whatever say I have something with
64 blocks of data if I split that up
into blocks of eight and I've got an
eight-core machine in an ideal world if
I ignore ignore like overhead for
scheduling and communication etc etc
each core would be able to do eight
blocks of this computation and I should
get speed-up
of about a factor of eight in an ideal
world but in the real world here this is
these these red blocks of the the CPU is
busy doing something okay it might be a
web browser it might be something else
it might be rendering it might be
something so what the kernel does what
the runtime library does is it uses a
different kind of scheduling where it
sets up a block of 64 and each core when
it can it goes and steals a block of
this work list and then does this
computation and that means that we can
even when some caused idle we can go and
get work from those cores and use them
on another core and so this this core is
doing like more than eight blocks of
work and this one is doing only two
because it was busy doing other things
but we still get some some reasonably
good speed-up not not the factor of
eight that was the ideal but something
that that's close enough to it so the
other thing that we've done with the new
runtime library is use a different
paralyzation strategy so in previous
versions of Mathematica we used
threading layer P threads on Linux or
whatever this is nice it's a very
powerful framework it's quite
complicated and difficult to extend if I
want to switch strategies for the
paralyzation it's a lot of code or not
of work to try and develop that and it's
quite heavy weight it's a very very high
latency for very simple tasks so the new
runtime library uses openmp open mps are
much more lightweight kind of threading
layer is tailored towards fast numerical
computation and it's much more ideal for
paralyzing vectorized operations for
examples it's got a very low latency
it's reasonably flexible it's got a
variety of built-in schedulers that have
been developed by people and there's
research work on them doing things like
work-stealing but we're stealing from a
nearby processor that has good cache
coherency for example things that will
be much more difficult for us to develop
the other things because it's an open
program you can also kind of pale
for your machine you can use environment
variables to say really give Mathematica
priority in my threads over any other
job that's running something like that
so here are some examples I'm going to
use a twenty core machine it's to
package Intel Xeon from about 2014 not
state-of-the-art but but we're a
reasonably nice machine the cash level
one cache is 32k level two cache 256 K
and level three cache is 2.5 six
megabytes in previous versions of
Mathematica we would try to ensure that
blocks would fit in level three cache
now using OMP we can use a smaller block
size and so you'll see a lot of the
speed-up comes from being able to work
around the the faster cache levels
you'll also see that the thresholds for
the o NP code a lower and some speed ups
the official lengths I should point out
that all of these examples are worst
case examples so they're really the
hardest things to paralyze I'm talking
about + x - subtract these are the
functions that really show the highest
overhead of communication in the threads
so here's machine integer speed-up so in
blue is the old code for threading and
in orange is the new OpenMP code so you
see around 8,000 in length the new onp
code starts to to work in parallel and
this is version 11.3 so this is the
serial speed up so we can get very close
to the actual twenty core that we're
using on the machine and this is the
actual execution time you see the OMP
starts to be able to paralyze quite for
quite short lengths and then it just
keeps using more and more core so the
execution time stays relatively constant
and then when it's got up to using all
20 calls then then then the extra 2
execution time increases when we get to
the very end here that's hardly any
speed-up and that's because we're
essentially spending all our time
fetching data from ram we're no longer
living in the cache and so when you get
to a very very large
the effects of paralyzation are lost so
it's only in this this kind of this kind
of length that you can't get any speed
up so about a factor of five for abs and
- about a factor of five for integer
plus subtract in times in the best case
the other thing that we did was to
rewrite the way that vector operations
work it's a so-called reduction
operation so reduction operation is when
you take a vector use some operation and
you get a scalar result so an example
that might be the maximum value okay the
maximum value operating on a vector
returns a scalar result or total total
will go and sum through the entries but
return a single entry as a result so
it's taking a vector space and returning
a scalar operation so what we did with
the new implementation was we've
reimplemented it to use voice thread
contention when it's going and working
on this computing its maximum value or
when it's going and working to compute
these sums in total each thread can now
accumulate its own partial result
without having to worry about what's
going on in the other threads and only
when all the threads are done it
combines the results together before
each block at each step would have to
recombine the results and there would be
kind of locking going on
causing sort of thread contention so
this is the result of maximum and this
is the result of total you see again but
a 20% speed-up a 20-fold speed excuse me
and even the the serial computation here
is about twice as fast this is the
result of real and complex arithmetic
so here again we get about 10 tenfold
speed-up on the average say two or three
times faster and the last thing that
we're able to do now that we don't have
restrictions of the machine under flow
is that we can use the faster arithmetic
libraries to compute complex from
complex elementary functions so one is
the absolute value it's now done through
mkl and this is the exponential
function and and what you see here is so
there are two two things going on here
one is that we're using mkl instead of C
code and that accounts for this this
region here this factor of three or four
speed-up and then the other one is the
fact that we're using OpenMP instead of
the threading that gives the additional
boost here so the short term plans to
continue the development of the runtime
well the next thing to do is arithmetic
or numeric arrays so if your two talked
about the actual numeric array data
structure that it stretches there you
can read read it out write it out
representing it we want to actually
allow users to be able to operate and
work on them and we want to allow them
to be used in the new compiler as a
representation to do things with another
one is to do single instruction multiple
data optimization so I was talking about
a parallel speed-up in the rain say ten
thousand to a million but all of the
arithmetic from say one to ten thousand
that's that's the interview that's the
range that we want to speed up now short
vector computations and the way to do
that is to try and block together
operations and push them through the CPU
pipeline say for a time something like
that depending on what instruction is
available on CPU nothing we want to look
at is parallel directives both inside
the wolfram runtime library and in the
gnu compiler we also need to generalize
the linear algebra you can leave for say
numeric arrays one allowed to be able to
call blas and an linnaeus of or whatever
with with floating point arrays or
matrices
another thing that we'd like to do is
move up to a slightly newer C++ standard
that has functions for example in Toms
talk we had an example of sorting so
there are this functionality that can
speed up sort of merge sort and and
other kinds of operations and there are
also a number of special functions
implemented in the new C++ tone
that we can make use of then we need to
reorganize the the WolframAlpha as a
dynamic library because there's interest
not just what we ought to share it
between the colonel and the and the new
compiler but also think about using in
other parts like like the front end so
some other things so so so we broke
we broke arithmetic with this underflow
that that was quite a substantial change
with a lot of impact we're thinking
about some more minor things so don't
have a heart attack you worth of that
usually much I'm talking about point
fixes so in the old days the focus of
mathematic was on mathematics okay so it
would say the arctangent of 0 is
indeterminate but I Triple E arithmetic
says it's an exceptional case it doesn't
really matter what value choose we're
going to choose the value of 0 okay so
so the fact that this one value across
the whole of arctan is different from
Mathematica prevents us from using and
faster floating-point arithmetic
libraries so what I've been doing is
going through the elementary functions
and cataloging these exceptional values
and what we'll try to do is move towards
at least some machine arithmetic I'm
only talked about if you want to do
symbolic calculations arctan Oh Vinnie
Zack zero will still be indeterminate as
you know you want the mathematical
definition but when you do
floating-point computations you want
something that matches the floating
point standard so so that's a bunch of
things that we're looking to change in
order to try to to make computations go
faster faster another thing might be to
add representations the I Triple E
infinity and Nan and then you could say
not switch to arbitrary precision
arithmetic
you could just say in a plot you'll get
an I Triple E infinity back but you'll
get it back quickly and you'll just
prune out and you won't pay the cost of
having to do the computation in
arbitrary position everything we're done
purely in machine position
that might also be something that the
front end won't be interested in and
also some other sort of minor changes
that type consistency so again it's a
kind of a mathematical decision when in
Mathematica when you take the imaginary
value of 2.3 you get an exact 0 okay but
really it should be a floating point
zero because it should be tight
consistent the input type is a
floating-point number the output type
should be a floating-point number
so in conclusion we're developing the
runtime library we're trying to make it
robust efficient type extensible for the
new compiler to support and extend to
successive types the incremental
improvements that we're building into
the runtime library aren't necessarily
tied to the new compiler so for example
the these improvements in this talk are
all in the next release we're trying to
provide a compact highly optimized core
computational base and then from that
core computational base people who want
functionality that's not in the Wolfram
runtime library will use the gnu
compiler and then the gnu compiler will
use the core functionality in the in the
in the runtime library and then you'll
be able to extend based on that through
the gnu compiler and the last thing is
it's really pushing the boundaries and
and quite an extensive stress test of
compilers and third-party libraries
we've found a number of bugs I've been
commuting computer communicating with
Intel we found a number of boats in MK
land our IP P error handling we create
standalone examples we send them off to
the developers which think it's
subsequently fixed we found a number of
both in microsoft visual studio complex
eps
exponential error handling has been
broken we found three or four separate
bugs sent them off to the developers and
they've been subsequently fixed we found
a number of bugs in GCC clang LLVM and
there is various of us communicate with
developers of these external compilers
and libraries to to
to resolve these issues so that we can
move forward so I hope that's given you
like an overview and I hope you found it
useful thank you very much
[Applause]